Mà chế là mấy quay hình bằng cách sép mà cầm là chắn đẹp.
Thấy chì tế thì hát, để chục đồ hả là mấy chứng đâu, rồi.
Thật hả là mấy chứng đâu, lắm.
Thì anh khắc hiện rồi đó, anh vào vô dạm sinh mẹ.
Bây giờ, anh biết cái sự tình ở đâu, quá lớn đi.
Mỗi lần thì hai thằng mở đi vô kể cửa hảm,
và anh dây cho đi là chạy vô, châu đó, lừng coi cái mái đó.
Hôm có lý khác cho những dịch mái,
trái đúng đến.
Mẹ nó có 2 đứa thích nè không để má mua trở
là thích rất là...
Hãy có...
Mấy giờ, mấy đặc mọi người đã mua viên.
Còn anh phải cho anh này là một đưa em gái nữa.
Mấy đêm gái thì nó bất...
Bọn tâm tâm tâm.
Điều lúc đó, hôm đó bàn quý vị,
mà không có chừng trái phát đi về nè.
Lấy mấy chúng sách.
Để chăm sách lên cái đếm mái là,
Đó là cái hình đó, cái hùng sông cái mà đo nhấn,
mục kai cái 2 hình trải vô khùng, đánh lên nhau.
Cái gì vậy mà, đánh xông cái mà, đánh trải ra lời,
nhấn cái nước, đánh đau koi.
Nhìn ở đây, mình mới ua đây rồi,
đánh đau khóng người quen, đau dành vầy.
Vậy đến 10 giờ, chứ vẻ đẹg màa xa,
em xíu, đẹg này nó bị cắt đầu rồi,
thì đó là cái hình trình đồng chiếm mắt đầu.